[Music]
rick and morty run away from the edward
without scissor hands towards the stairs
but then somehow wind up on these set of
stairs instead of the ones on the
original trajectory this could be
possible of course but the show doesn't
animate them jumping or rocketing over
there which would have been a lot of fun
to see also has this alien planet just
randomly heard of mcs sure do they just
have their own mcesher i'm gonna need to
walk up a few more impossible staircases
to figure this one out
well that's what you get for building
your escher palace over a space vortex
morty let's watch some interdimensional
cable remember how we used to do that i
do and if you want to remember i will
show you these two examples of videos
you could watch that do not benefit me
in any way i'm just looking out for you
i can't go on i i can't go on like this
with the truth tortoise in my head i was
just thinking this the last time i let a
tortoise on my head wait this morty is
my archive of all the experiences you've
begged me to remove from your life lest
you go insane i call them mortys mind
blowers seems like an impressive amount
when you see them all but how many of
them are just simply about morty for
getting the mind blowers room exists
because rick would have to erase that
memory every time as well right also
morty's memory manipulation would be
more accurate but rick is taking the
marketing approach here to keep this
intriguing like calling botox a
rejuvenating enhancement rather than
paralyzing injection jabs or a piece of
house a unique canvas ready for creative
solutions this labeling system that
appears to depend on the stickiness of
the tape certainly rick has the ability
to do better than this okay so rick
doesn't give a [ __ ] but why then label
it all i've never seen signs of a
regular dude as you describe him hanging
out up there but rick does have the
technology to take the memory from morty
at this point so why not looking at
morty's memory and see what he did to
confirm the person on the moon or tease
morty endlessly for the rest of his life
putting brown gravy on mashed potatoes
or really just putting brown gravy on
anything morty's at least 11 or 12 right
why are they still learning simple math
like 18 plus 10 at his age morty took a
picture in printable clarity at night
wait morty printed pictures for proof
this is insane who prints pictures oh my
god what have i done how did this memory
not convince morty that he'd actually
seen a man on the moon his memory is
clear at the beginning and this is
obviously a man and not a smudge also
this is the same flag on the moon as in
the yard there is no other conclusion to
draw from this memory except morty was
correct about the man on the moon they
don't all have titles though it's not a
simpsons halloween special more like a
clip show made of clips you never saw
these are clips that morty never saw
these are clips that morty can't
remember but he definitely saw them at
some point or they wouldn't exist the
collector comes to peek into their
habitat and spots rick disassembling a
television wouldn't this be somewhat
alarming why would the collector allow
the specimens to take apart their
environment oh the schematics specify a
second smaller pilot i mean they really
specify smaller they have to be exactly
five foot three but why morty normally
just sits in normal sized seats what
would his height have to do with
anything in regards to the schematics
and rick's making it pretty obvious
these idiots are being set up to be
stuck in an alien human zoo how come i
was able to see those other people's
memories i i wouldn't have been around
for that morty would be nootropic at tv
sins this very confusing piece of paper
that came from an alien but is written
in english now maybe the paper is
designed to translate to be legible to
whoever reads it but then why wouldn't
it be written properly with the name
capitalized in a period after warrior
having two glasses of whatever this is
while also having a glass of whatever
this is is that orange juice oh great
now i'm thinking about oj with mexican
food and you can take that flavor combo
straight to hell rick and morty i'm
gonna go take a quick sh so rick goes to
the bathroom and walks away down the
hallway i thought that was odd because i
assumed the bathroom doors were here
then the shot cuts to floop and over his
shoulder the sign says the bathrooms are
the opposite direction from where rick
went however on the wide shot the arrow
is pointed in the other direction and
we're left with nothing but assumptions
about where rick actually went to take a
[ __ ] honestly this is probably the most
haunting part of the episode all right
so you want to do this here or outside
i'm not privy to all the donkuco
establishment rules but i'm gonna go out
on a limb and assume they don't approve
of alien murder in their restaurant
during normal operation hours in the
meantime enjoy a grab bag of mind
blowers i call poop aids underscore copy
and by grab bag he means two two scenes
does not a grab bag make you simply have
to choose summer
summer okay go with me here sure beth
had that answer at the ready far too
quickly but really the blame is on this
alien for not creating a soundproof
torture bubble grandpa rick there must
be some scientific way to save him the
visuals are saying wind the audio is
saying wind but the lack of wind in
anyone's hair other than morty is saying
continuity issue well i guess it's nice
to know the whole family sucks it took
you almost three seasons to realize that
rick opens the door panel by hitting it
with his fist but doesn't he know the
shooting door panels is the official way
to make sci-fi doors open for the fun of
the show these two have just wiped
almost all of their memories but all
indication is that the mind wiper would
only wipe one specific memory and not an
identity see those two fleshy sacks
under his chin morty
grab them not specifying which of the
six fleshy sacks you're talking about
we're partners i guess and we fight
aliens like men in black morty can't
remember who he is but he conveniently
remembers the movie men in black where
one of the main plot lines was about a
device that could wipe out people's
memories scooping up a potentially
compromised memory tube from the broken
pile on the floor rather than selecting
one of the many pristine tubes from the
nearby shelves leaving your interstellar
laboratory garage door wide open
this audible beep would give rick all
the indicators he needs to know that the
machine is being accessed by morty
there's no way he wouldn't hear it and
try to stop him from ruining whatever
morty is inevitably about to ruin there
i'm done just stay out of trouble
believing this would work
what's the point of going on if most of
everything that happens just ends up
sitting in here my thoughts on cloud
storage somehow make their way into this
episode you guys doing morty's mind
blowers asks the ice pop eating sister
who conveniently wanders into the garage
and enters the bunker only seconds
before her family ends the episode with
a bang which is almost as convenient as
some are also wearing a key necklace
needed to access the panel that will
save rick and morty i'm saying this is
too convenient and rick and morty should
be dead
there is no way she consumed each of the
steps on that card that quickly and you
should never do step number one without
reading all the remaining steps to
ensure there's no [ __ ] regarding step
number one in the following steps
especially when step one requires you to
shoot people also making me say steps
too many times no wonder you're
constantly fighting with each other and
behind schedule that's a funny way of
saying i should have just kept your
memories white because you're both
[ __ ]
well uh
technically speaking the procedure is
brain damage this is the story of a boy
with scissors for hands
return the truth tortoise
you have no power over me
what the hell is this a center for ants
you want thingamabobs
i got 20.
[Music]
but i do have a thing oh god do i have
to keep looking then grab boys don't
kill him i will